[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now eric
palacios and associates the sponsor of
this next segment is back to update us
on coveted vaccination requirements and
restrictions here's our conversation
eric welcome back
hi rocky good to see you good to see you
too the vaccination saga continues so
let's talk vaccines first question here
are any vaccines mandatory
that's a great question and the answer
is no no a state
government or or the federal government
mandates any type of vaccine at this
point
the biden administration has also
made it clear that they don't approve of
a mandatory vaccination
or the carrying of a vaccination card or
passport for our citizens
okay and can private companies make the
vaccination required for their patrons
or their employees this is a this is a
big question for people
it is and uh private companies can
request that their uh employees are
including their patrons uh be vaccinated
so at this time that's what we're seeing
with some of the local
venues uh like the raiders for instance
just made it a requirement that
everybody attained their games be fully
vaccinated yeah so what's the reasoning
behind requiring employees or patrons to
be vaccinated why are they doing well
generally if you require something like
this it's for the safety of your other
employees and uh your patrons
and also to limit your liability
exposure in case somebody gets sick and
they decide to take legal action against
you okay that's a good point that's a
good point um do those who have chosen
not to get vaccinated are they able to
fight against that with their employer
are they do they take any legal action
there's very limited things that they
can do uh and what's nice is that most
entities in las vegas in nevada have
given their employees a choice it's
either get vaccinated or submit uh to
regular uh testing to make sure that uh
that you're negative uh and that's
always helpful to to accommodate your
employees but in case that they don't
there's two instances where you can
have uh some a protection or a way to
fight back one is if
your employer or any company or business
is violating uh the constitution or a
federal law and this can be if
they don't allow you to exercise your
your freedom of religion
or if you have a disability and because
of that you cannot get the vaccine and
they still won't accommodate you so
those are the the two main reasons
or ways that you can fight back and
hopefully get an accommodation if anyone
has any questions or they're just
looking for a good resource to find more
about the vaccinations and their legal
restrictions where should they go
well there's a lot of information
available online if you have specific
questions as to your case and here in
nevada you can call us at 444-7777
and we'll be happy to answer any
questions and guide you in the right
direction
thank you to eric palacios and
associates for sponsoring this segment
for more information give them a call at
we'll be 702-444-7777